er hat es mir hoch und heilig
versprochen der Verkäufer bei uns kann
ist sowas nicht möglich und da zieht es
einem Boden weg jetzt muss ich halt
neben der Miete die die Zinsen zahlen
die kreditarbeiter bedienen sie haben
Eigentumswohnungen gekauft Kredite
aufgenommen und Erspartes investiert nun
droht ihr Lebenstraum zu platzen eine
gewaltige immobilienpleitewelle rauscht
durch Deutschland tausende von Wohnungen
drohen wegzubrechen
wir sollten hier eigentlich schon im
Juli eingezogen sein man ist irgendwo
weiß ich nicht zwischen Fuß Traurigkeit
Motivation Ärger hast wie Villa Rose mit
diesem klangvollen Namen hat das
Unternehmen Projekt Immobilien diesen
Wohnkomplex in Berlin Pankow beworben 52
Wohnungen im Stil zu 100% verkauft
eigentlich sollten die Arbeiten längst
abgeschlossen sein stattdessen
Stillstand denn der Projektentwickler
ist pleite
ich bin jetzt Rentner und wollte das als
sicherer Rente all das Gerechte Wohnung
wollte da einziehen und wollte meinen
Rest Jahre halt da verbringen zunächst
verlief alles nach Plan erzählt Özkan so
Kurse er hat bereits mehrere
hunderttausend Euro für seine
Penthousewohnung angezeigt ich habe
jetzt zwei Wohnungen ich habe mir gehört
das komplette Terrasse und das komplette
Reich ich habe Durchbruch machen lassen
doch der versprochene Einzug verzögert
sich immer wieder anfangs zahlte Projekt
Immobilien dafür noch monatliche
Verzugsstrafen dann war auch damit
Schluss gewisser Weise habe ich mich
täuschen lassen auch durch diese
verzugszahlung obwohl sie eigentlich in
meinem Interesse war ne und dann kam ein
Punkt wo diese Zahlung nicht mehr an dem
Tag haben wo sie immer kam sondern nicht
mehr kam
ich natürlich Rabatt gemacht und gefragt
warum weshalb wieso die Zahlungen
blieben aus die Antworten auch doch
warum dafür lohnt ein Blick auf das
Geschäftsmodell in der Regel steuert
eine Dachgesellschaft z.B eine Holding
einzelne Projektgesellschaften zu so
einer Projektgesellschaft zählt zum
Beispiel auch das vivella Rose
Grundstücke werden erschlossen bebaut
Wohnungen verkauft ein prächtig
funktionierendes Geschäftsmodell solange
die Zinsen niedrig sind doch mit dem
extrem hohen Zinsanstieg ist der Markt
zusammengebrochen
allein Projekt Immobilien unterhält
knapp 120 solcher Wohnbauprojekte in
Deutschland und die Hälfte davon
insolvent das aber könne gar nicht
passieren wurde den Käufern des viveros
versichert wo die mir das verkauft haben
haben die gesagt wir haben einen Topf
ihr müsst euch das so vorstellen wir
haben schon die
die Menschen die hier Geld investiert
haben wir haben schon alles schon in der
Topf drinne was wir benötigen ihr müsst
jetzt hier nur noch unterschreiben dann
werdet ihr euch auch hier ohne Kopf zu
machen ich meinte was ist wenn ihr in
Insolvenz irgendwie an oder irgendwas
passiert er hat es mir hoch und heilig
versprochen der Verkäufer bei uns kann
ist sowas nicht möglich nun befürchten
sie dass ein Teil ihres Geld dafür
benutzt wurde um Löcher an anderer
Stelle zu stopfen so etwas Zeit durchaus
denkbar sagt Fachanwalt Stefan Jäger
das heißt man schließt die
Finanzierungslücken die sich in dem ein
oder anderen Objekt aufgetan haben damit
dass man einfach ein neues Projekt
beginnt weil man weiß dass die erste
Anzahlung so hoch sein wird dass man
davon einen Teil abzweigen kann um das
notleitende Projekt vielleicht noch ans
rettende Ufer zu bringen sollten
Querfinanzierungen dieser Art
stattgefunden haben wäre das ein klarer
Verstoß gegen geltendes Recht und
möglicherweise auch ein Fall für die
Staatsanwaltschaft es ist eine untreue
eine Untreue gegenüber den Käufern denen
ja versprochen ist dass das Geld für das
Bauvorhaben dass sie fertig bauen sollen
verwendet wird und zwar ausschließlich
und es ist eine wie ich gesagt habe aus
dem bauförderungssicherungsgesetz
abgeleitete Untreue die dem
Bauhandwerker gegenüber zur persönlichen
Haftung führt also es ist eine nicht
gestattete Querfinanzierung das wird
dennoch gemacht aber wenn es rauskommt
ist es nicht so schön
auch in diesem Rohbau mitten im
Düsseldorfer Zentrum waren Dutzende von
Wohnungen geplant seit Wochen ist die
Baustelle Verlassen der
Projektentwickler insolvent
wenige Kilometer entfernt ein ähnliches
Bild ein weiterer Rohbau auf dem die
Arbeiten stillstehen auch in Düsseldorf
bangen hunderte Käufer jetzt um
Wohnungen und Geld
Düsseldorfs planungsdezernentin Cornelia
tuschke beobachtet diese Pleitewelle mit
Sorge sie hatte fest mit der
Fertigstellung gerechnet nun stehen
allein in NRWs Landeshauptstadt mehrere
hundert Wohnungen auf der Kippe
mir macht's große Kopfzerbrechen weil
wir stehen natürlich auch in den
Prozessen draußen bei den Menschen wir
sehen wie die Wohnungen gebraucht werden
und von daher ist das natürlich eine
sehr sehr schwierige Situation weil es
eben auch zum Teil halbfertige Projekte
gibt die vielleicht nicht fertiggestellt
werden und man kann nur hoffen dass die
Projekte die schon weit fortgeschritten
sind dann eben auch weiterentwickelt
werden von dem auch immer und dass das
Geld aufgetrieben wird dass das auch
geht aber es ist natürlich insbesondere
für die Betroffenen eine fast nicht
auszuhaltende Situation
Baustopp und Pleiten nicht mehr in
Berlin und Düsseldorf ein Problem in
fast allen größeren Städten drohen Bau
Ruinen und brachen denn immer mehr
namhafte Projektentwickler bellten
aufgrund hoher Baukosten und Zinsen
insolvenzern die Pleitewelle werde wohl
noch größere Kreise ziehen vermuten
Experten
wir haben ein unglaublich kleinteiligen
Markt mit rund 16.000 Bauträgern in
Deutschland und da sind einfach viele
die von einzelnen Projekten abhängen und
da werden wir noch mehr Insolvenzen
erleben gerade auch von den kleinen
kriegt man das gar nicht so mit und das
bedeutet natürlich auch dass die
Bautätigkeit enorm zurückgeht das heißt
wir werden in den nächsten Jahren
wahrscheinlich deutlich weniger bauen
als wir benötigen für den ohnehin schon
angespannten Wohnungsmarkt ein
Alarmsignal denn allein im ersten
Halbjahr 2023 sind Wohnbauprojekte
gegenüber dem Vorjahreszeitraum um 54%
eingebrochen die Formel ist eigentlich
ganz einfach denn wenn nicht genug
gebaut wird gibt es zu wenige Wohnungen
am Wohnungsmarkt für viele tausend
Menschen die Wohnungen suchen derzeit
fehlen über 700.000 Wohnungen am
deutschen Mietmarkt und das zeigt am
Ende auch die Konsequenz für ja den
sozialen Sprengstoff den es zweifelsfrei
gibt die Leute können sich wohnen in
Deutschland heute kaum noch leisten um
pleitewellen künftig hingegen zu steuern
und mehr Wohnraum zu schaffen hat die
Stadt Düsseldorf jetzt einen
Maßnahmenpaket dazu zählen zum Beispiel
Vorkaufsrechte für unbebaute Grundstücke
als auch Förderung sozialer Wohnprojekte
Bauvorhaben die allein auf kurzfristigen
Gewinn ziehen sollen es künftig schwerer
haben
die Städte das Land die öffentliche Hand
braucht
gemeinwohlorientierten Wohnungsbau das
kann aber auch über Genossenschaften
über kirchliche Träger über
gemeinwohlträger im Allgemeinen auch
geregelt werden und ich glaube das sind
gute Partner denn die agieren aus dem
Bestand heraus die Planen nicht um zu
verkaufen sondern die planen um größere
Bestände zu haben die sie gut vermieten
können und zwar in allen Bereichen der
Gesellschaft und das sind die
Gesellschaften die bauen im Moment auch
noch die bauen vielleicht nicht so groß
und nicht so viel und nicht so gewaltig
aber die bauen stetig und kontinuierlich
weiter
Gemeinwohl orientiert das hatte wie
Villa Rose nie versprochen dafür aber 52
Wohnungen nun hängt alles ab vom
Insolvenzverwalter er muss entscheiden
ob die laufenden Verträge erfüllt oder
der Weiterbau eingestellt wird für viele
Käufer wäre das der finanzielle Ruin und
für das Stadtbild eine weitere hässliche
Bau Ruine